salut les cinq plus grosses arnaques qu'
y a eu en France ce sont des arnaques
sans violence sans crime sans menace
mais qui ont rapporté des millions parce
qu'il y a des gens ils sont assez malins
pour avec quelques mots et une petite
embrouille rapporter des diamants ou des
valises de cache en entier alors oui je
sais c'est pas mon décor habituel parce
que on est à un endroit un peu spécial
pour une soirée de lancement d'un truc
qui qui existe depuis quelques jours il
y a un indice je vous en reparle dans la
vidéo il y a personne qui a l'abri
d'être volé même quand on appartient à
la cour du roi le roi Louis X le père de
Louis XV avait pour maîtresse Jeanne
duarry il était tellement amoureux
d'elle qu'il a commandé au joyer de la
cour un collier de diamant qui
surpassait tout ce qu'on avait pu voir
et compris le prix 1,6 million de livres
sauf qu'au moment de les vendre au roi
le roi est mort et du coup il a pas eu
le temps de l'acheter alors qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont fait les joyer de la cour
d'après vous bah c'est simple ils sont
allés voir son descendant pour qu'il
achète le collier mais Marie-Antoinette
elle n'en voulait pas il y a une logique
derrière ça c'est quand même prévu pour
la maîtresse du roi à la base passons à
notre arnaqueuse madame de la mode qui
rentre en jeu elle savait que le
cardinal de rouan était é très amoureux
de Marie- Antoinette mais qu'elle
refusait même de lui adresser la parole
hop hop hopopop petite rectification il
n'était pas amoureux de la reine c'est
surtout qu'en fait il avait un passif
avec la mère de marie-anttoinette qui
avait demandé à sa fille de ne plus lui
adresser la parole du coup il était plus
vraiment en odeur de sainteté auprès de
la reine et il voulait rattraper le coup
la motte va voir le cardinal elle se
fait passer pour la principale
confidente de Marie-Antoinette ce qui
est faux hein et elle lui promet de
faire son possible pour les réconcilier
tous les deux elle va faire semblant
d'entretenir une correspondance fictive
entre le cardinal et la reine le
cardinal écrit une let à
Marie-Antoinette et la mote rédige les
réponses en signant du nom de
marie-anttoinette de France là déjà le
cardinal il aurait dû se rendre compte
de la supercherie parce que les reines
de France signaient toujours par leur
prénom seul elle ne précisait jamais de
France et là ça commence à briller fort
la mote l'arnaqueuse elle organise un
rendez-vous nocturne entre le cardinal
et un susi de la reine dans la pénombre
il va y voir que du feu il va vraiment
croire qu'il s'adresse à la reine
jusqu'au jour où dans un courrier la
reine demande dem au cardinal de lui
envoyer le fameux collier prétextant
qu'elle peut pas se l'acheter elle-même
après l'avoir refusé au départ et elle
lui promet de faire passer la somme
l'argent par la motte l'escroc qui va
ensuite lui donner afin que lui il
puisse rémunérer les joyers alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe d'après vous bah
c'est pas compliqué le cardinal va voir
les joyers il récupère les bijoux il les
passe à la mote et aussitôt les bijoux
en main la mote et son mari vont
s'empresser de vendre le collier en
petite pièce détachée les semaines vont
passer le cardinal ne voit toujours pas
l'argent arriver si ce n'est 30000
livres quand même que la mote lui a
donné pour le faire patienter au bout de
plusieurs mois les joyers qui étaient
toujours pas payés décident d'aller
directement à la cour pour demander des
explications à la reine le cardinal de
Ran je sais pas comment ils ont pu
croire que ça allait marcher et aussitôt
convoqué à Versailles il explique toute
la situation bien sûr il va découvrir
que marie-anttoinette n'a jamais
correspondu avec lui et qu'elle n'a
jamais eu le collier dans sa possession
notre chère Madame de la mode va prendre
une peine de prison à perpétuité tandis
que son mari va se faire la mal en
Angleterre le collier de la reine
c'était malin mais bon elle a quand même
fini en prison au final alors que le
prochain
lui il s'est pas attaqué à un collier il
s'est attaqué à la tour
effffel parlons maintenant de Victor
Lustig la première fois que j'ai parlé
de lui sur cette chaîne cé en 2016 pour
raconter bah un petit peu cette arnaque
je vous en reparle parce que 7 ans on
passé vous connaissiez peut-être pas la
chaîne à l'époque on est en 1925 à Paris
Victor ltigl le journal et il voit que
la torfel va devoir avoir des gros
travaux très chers de réparation et
d'entretien donc il est plutôt envisagé
qu'elle soit détruite et c'est là que
ltig va profiter de la situation pour
créer une super cherie très complexe il
va se faire passer pour un haut
fonctionnaire du gouvernement français
et il va contacter les cinq plus gros
ferrailleurs de la capitale ce qui
achète la ferraille à pas cher pour en
faire autre chose avec la torfl il y a
de quoi faire tout ça est tenu secret
alors lors de réunion secrète le Stig va
annoncé au ferraayor que la tourfel va
être démantelée et réduite en pièce
détachée bien sûr il demande que cette
affaire reste secrète tant que le
contrat n'est pas signé au risque de
déchaîner une sorte de tempête
médiatique sur les cinq ferrailleurs il
y en a un qui va mordre à l'hameçon il
s'appelle André poisson poisson hameçon
bah il était destiné André poisson
c'était le plus introverti des cinq et
surtout il voulait à tout prix se faire
une place dans le monde des affaires
c'était un peu le le rooki le genau il
est tellement motivé qu'il va donner dès
le lendemain à Lustig une enveloppe de
100000 francs pour acheter la dame de
fer au moment même où il va empocher
l'argent ltig va prendre la fuite en
Autriche parce qu'il s'attend à avoir
son nom en gros titre dans la presse
pour son escroquerie sauf que les jours
passent les semaines passent et rien
n'apparaît dans la presse pourquoi parce
que André poisson avait tellement honte
de cette F aussi bêtement qu' va pas
porter plainte et il va pas oser le dire
à qui que ce soit au contraire il va
tout faire pour étouffer l'affaire donc
c'est tout BF pour le stick il va
rentrer à Paris pour revendre la Tour
Effel une deuxième
fois vraiment c'est de la gourmandise là
et la gourmandi c'est un Vilin défaut
parce que le client est moins crédule et
là Lustig va se faire arrêter condamner
à 4 mois de prison juste pour vous dire
la suite de l'ustig ça va pas l'arrêter
il va ensuite aller aux États-Unis pour
vendre une machine qui imprime des
billets et des fraudes mais qui sont à
chaque fois quand même très audacieuse
quand on connait un peu le milieu des
arnaques Lustig on connaît mais spadjari
c'est celui qu'on a surnommé le cas du
siècle tellement c'est brillant si vous
connaissez pas son histoire vous allez
adorer on est dans les années 70 et il
se dit qu'il va arrêter les petites
escroqueries qu'il fait dans sa vie pour
se lancer dans une vie normale il va
s'installer à Nice où il est photograp
de mariage d'ailleurs il va faire
quelques reportages pour la mairie et
alors qu'il fait un reportage sur la
société général à Nice il apprend qu'il
y a pas d'alarme dans la banque ça
semble fou mais c'est vrai à cette
époque il y a pas d'alarme dans la
banque là c'est un truc à la oan eleven
il va recruter des malfr direct pour
constituer son équipe au total ils vont
être 12 le plan est simple ils vont
passer par les éigou ils vont creuser un
tunnel de 8 m jusqu'à la salle des
coffres 7 mai 1976 ils sont dans les
égouts en train de creuser un tunnel
burin chalumeau système de ventilation
il y a tout ils mettent même de la
moquette pour que ça fasse moins de
bruit ça va leur prendre 2 mois le 16
juillet 1976 c'est un vendredi soir il
leur reste plus qu'un seul mur à percer
pour directement accéder à la salle des
coffres une fois que tout le personnel
est parti ils détruisent le dernier mur
et se retrouve dans la salle des coffres
sans qu'aucune alarme ne s'enclenche ils
sont donc en train d'ouvrir les coffres
au chalumeau à la masse ils trouent bien
sûr des bijoux des du du liquide des
objets de valeur on est loin du braquage
qui se fait en de minut de chrono non là
ils ont tout le temps ils ont un weekend
entier devant eux seulement dans la nuit
de samedi il y a une pluie diluvien à
Nice et ils ont peur que les égouts
soient inondés et qu'il puissent pas
ressortir du coup il repart plutôt prévu
avec quand même l'équivalent de 30
millions d'euros mais parce qu' mais sur
l'un des coffres qu'ils ont fracturé les
braqueurs ont laissé derrière eux un
message qui continue sans doute à
nourrir aujourd'hui la légende et vous
avez sûrement déjà entendu le message
est ni armes ni violence et sans haine
une fois qu'ils sont sortis toute la
bande a pris la fuite et spadjari est
parti aux États-Unis avec sa part du
gâteau le lundi matin tout le monde a
appris que la Société Générale avait été
braquée et on parle très vite dans les
médias du cas du siècle la police met la
main sur certains des membres du groupe
qui vont tous dénoncer spadari comme
étant la tête pensante comme quoi le
neur chez le malfroise pas toujours il
se fera donc à arrêté le 27 octobre à
l'aéroport de Nice et après avoir un
petit peu nié il a fini par avouer les
faits d'ailleurs il avoue assez vite
parce que spadjari dans le fond il était
fier de son coup et c'est là que ça
devient un scénario de film le 10 mars
1977 le jour du procès au tribunal de
Nice padjari se retrouve dans le bureau
du juge il lui dessine le plan de la
banque pour lui expliquer comment il a
fait il donne des détails il donne les
noms il se lève de la table il ouvre la
fenêtre et il saute spanjari sauve de 8
m il atterrit au sol sur le toit d'une
voiture et là il retrouve un complice
qui l'attendait sur une moto pour
s'évader au final spadarry sera en
cabale pendant 12 ans jusqu'à ce qu'il
meurt d'un cancer spat Jarry c'était les
années 70 mais vous avez remarqué on
augmente d'année en année et là on passe
à notre époque à nous 2016 le voleur au
Main d'Or encore une
bijouterie cette arnaque là c'est une
comme je les aime elle aurait pu
m'inspirer d'ailleurs un jeu comme
arnaque bluff et diamant arnaque bluff
et diamant c'est un jeu de stratégie et
de bluff donc qui est inspiré d'une
véritable arnaque de 193 39 que j'ai
raconté sur cette chaîne en
2018 bonsoir ou plutôt bonjour ça dépend
à l'heure à laquelle vous regardez et
c'est surtout mon premier vrai jeu de
société j'avais fait un jeu d'ambiance
il y a très longtemps ce qu'on appelle
un jeu àéro mais là c'est un jeu de
société pour l'occasion et pour la
première fois de ma vie j'ai fait une
soirée de lancement j'en fais pas
forcément pour les livres mais là je
voulais en faire une parce qu'on allait
pouvoir jouer tous ensemble décembre
2016 un homme appelle une bijouterie de
luxe à Paris situé rue de la boessie il
dit qu'il est le courtier d'un très
riche homme d'affaires et il demande un
showroom privé dans la bijouterie pour
analyser deux bagues et deux diamants
bruts et ça c'est des demandes assez
courantes hein le 30 décembre le
courtier va à 10h du matin de la
bijouterie demande à étudier de plus
près les bagues et surtout les diamants
tout se passe comme prévu le courtier et
l'expert se retrouent avec les écrins
dans les mains il manipule il analyse
les bijoux mais après analyse il leur
dit que ça va pas plaire à son client et
il leur rend les bijoux et il repart
tranquillement tout va bien sauf que 2h
après son départ le bijoutier se rend
compte que les écrins sont pas tout à
fait les mêmes et surtout que les
diamants qui y a à l'intérieur et les
bacs qui a à l'intérieur sont en toc ils
viennent de se faire faire taper 5,5
millions d'euros de bijou alors comment
notre magicien a fait je vais vous le
faire voir avec ces deux cartes à jouer
imaginons que le CAD de carot que je
plie en quatre ce soit une des bagues
originales celle qui vaut vraiment de
l'argent notre escroc connaît très bien
cette bague et de son côté il fabrique
un faux relativement crédible qui
résistera pas un examen approfondi mais
juste assez crédible visuellement et on
va le symboliser le faux par le cadre de
trèfle ça ça vaut des millions ça ça
vaut rien il doit faire une technique de
magicien qu'on appelle le shuttle pass
le Shuttle pass ça consiste à passer un
objet dans l'autre main mais à le garder
en rétention dans la première main pour
faire croire que ce qui avait déjà en
rétention de la deuxième main est
l'original qu'on vient de faire passer
j'ai ici ma fausse bague dans la main de
l'autre côté j'ai la vraie bague
l'expert regarde la bague il l'analyse
il la soupèse probablement il la passe
dans notre main il la reg regarde et il
dit non non ça me plaît pas je vous la
Redonne et il redonne le faux puisque le
vrai est encore d' ça j'imagine qu'en
plus il habitué l'œil du bijoutier en
faisant ce genre de geste pour à un
moment donné ne pas transférer la bague
et vous voyez que dans le fond c'est une
technique plutôt simple quand on la
maîtrise bien d'autant qu'il a créé une
inattention en faisant sonner son
téléphone et c'est aussi là qu'il en a
profité pour intervertir les deux écrans
dans le mouvement les bijoutiers ont
évidemment tout de suite alerté la
police et là c'est carrément toute la
police internationale qui s'est mise sur
le coup pour l'arrêter pourquoi la
police internationale parce que cette
façon de faire est bien connue des
services de police c'est même la
signature de cette personne on l'appelle
le voleur romain d'or son vrai nom c'est
George ploscaru un rouain de 42 ans qui
appartient à un gang de SEP personnes à
peine sorti de la bijouterie il est
reparti en voiture avec sa compagne en
direction de la Roumanie et une fois en
Roumanie je vous passe tous les détails
mais ils sont partis pour Bucharest où
un client les attendait une fois sorti
de son hôtel à Bucharest George s'est
rendu chez l'un de ses complices et là
la
police mais c'était malin quand même
mais pas bien la prochaine c'est pas une
histoire particulière c'est une arnaque
qui a eu lieu des dizaines des dizaines
peut-être des centaines de fois on sait
pas ça s'appelle l'arnaque à la
paire cette dernière arnaque c'est pas
une seule arnaque c'est une méthodologie
qui a pas mal tourné qui a sûrement
encore lieu mais beaucoup moins qu'avant
parce qu'elle est connue un bijoutier
qui tient une joillerie de grand
prestige a parfois du mal à trouver des
clients donc il peut voir son chiffre
d'affair baissé de jour en jour et là
imaginez qu'il y a un client qui rentre
avec une allure d'homme très riche avec
sûrement des vêtements de luxe peut-être
même un chauffeur une belle voiture et
imaginez qu'en plus le client est cl
dans sa demande il souhaite offrir un
bijou d'exception à sa femme pour un
anniversaire de mariage et il va jusqu'à
préciser que l'argent n'est pas un
obstacle bon bah le bijoutier ça lui
plaît comme demande dans l'une des
histoires qui s'est vraiment passé le
bijoutier en question a décidé de passer
aux choses sérieuses et d'aller chercher
une pièce unique dans son coffre qui
coûtait un million d'euros le client
était ravi il lui a dit que c'était
exactement ce qu'il lui fallait et qu'il
le prenait sauf qu'il voudrait en plus
un deuxième diamant d'exceptions comme
ça rigoureusement identique pour mon
monter l'ensemble en boucle d'oreille
pour sa femme mais attention là il y a
pas d'arnaque hein le client paye le
bijou à million d'euros et repart avec
son diamant unique bien sûr le bijoutier
activé tout de suite son réseau
international pour trouver la copie de
ce bijou c'est pas une chose simple et
c'est même fort probable qu'il ne trouve
jamais le jumeau de ce diamant mais là
notre Boutier est chanceux au bout de
quelques jours un confrère lui basé en
Belgique lui confirme avoir la réplique
exacte du bijou souci le vendeur demande
1,5 million d'euros pour vendre son
bijou donc le bijoutier appelle son
client et lui propose l'affaire pour 2
million d'euros vous avez vu comment on
passe de 1,5 million à 2 million ça fait
une belle commission quand même en tout
cas ça arrête pas le client qui répond
acheter là je viens la chercher la
semaine prochaine le bijoutier s'exécute
il achète la pièce 1,5 million d'euros
que le vendeur belge lui envoie sans
délai donc toujours pas d'arnaque la
semaine suivante le bijoutier ne voit
pas l'acheteur rentrer dans sa boutique
il appelle donc son client pour lui
demander ce qu'il en est et le verdict
tombe ça l'intéresse plus sa femme l'a
quitté il ne veut plus du diamant est-ce
que vous avez compris ce qui s'est passé
où allit l'AR des deux pièces uniques
elles étaient pas uniques c'était en
réalité une seule et même pièce le
prétendu client était un escroc qui a
trouvé le moyen de revendre 1,5 million
d'euros le bijou qui venait d'acheter 1
million d'euros et tout ça au même
bijoutier ça s'appelle l'arnaque à la
paire et dans notre exemple il a quand
même empoché 500000 € sans le moindre
risque d'aller en prison quand même
malin pas bien mais c'est malin
maintenant vous devez comprendre
pourquoi j'ai écrit un jeu dont la
thématique c'est une véritable histoire
de vol de diamants parce que je suis un
petit peu fan de ça je dis pas que c'est
bien mais je dis que quand même à chaque
fois ils sont malins et tout le jeu
arnaque bleu fait diamant est basé sur
une histoire vraie d'un vol en 1939 sans
he sans armes juste avec de la
manipulation mais en plus très légère
quoi vous pouvez découvrir la vidéo où
je présente tout le jeu et la partie je
vous mets le lien dans la description le
jeu est disponible partout dans les
librairies les boutiques les grandes
surfaces en ligne depuis le 12 octobre
donc je comprends même pas que vous avez
pas encore votre exemplaire merci
d'avoir regardé la vidéo je m'appelle
toujours Fabien licard à très bientôt
Ciao